Transcriber: Joseph Geni
Reviewer: Ivana Korom
It's funny how foreigners
ask me the same questions
when they first meet me.
Questions like,
"Wow, you're from Mongolia?
So do you ride horses to go to work?"
"Do you know what Coke is?"
Or, "Do you have chocolates in Mongolia?"
And if I want to have fun with it,
I say things like,
"Oh my God,
I've never heard any of those before.
What are Coke and chocolates?
Can you tell me more about them?"
It always works,
and we have a good laugh about it too.
In reality, our capital city,
Ulaanbaatar, is very urban.
We have commercial buildings,
brand-name hotels
and beautiful art spaces too.
But all too often
foreigners fixate on what Mongolia lacks.
They look at our massive,
untouched landscape,
traditional nomadic lifestyles,
and see it as a sign of poverty.
And I disagree.
In fact, I think there's
a lot we can learn
from ancient Mongolian nomads
that will help us survive
in the years and decades to come.
This is a picture of me playing Mongolia's
most celebrated traditional instrument,
morin khuur,
or horsehead fiddle.
I started playing the instrument
when I was only nine,
and by 11 I was traveling the world
representing Mongolia
at international festivals,
living and studying in places like Japan,
China, Finland, Germany and Sweden.
But then suddenly,
when I was 21,
I lost my loving mother,
and just two years later
I lost my father.
As an only child,
I was devastated and lonely.
At the time, the only thing
I had left was my country,
so I decided to move home.
When I was lost with sorrow,
my country gave me a feeling
of safety and belonging.
I imagined eternal the blue sky
of Mongolia as my father
and the untouched, gorgeous
landscape as my mother.
Having lived in developed countries
for over a decade,
I became very distant
from the nomadic lifestyles,
so I wanted to reconnect
and experience it for myself.
I often journeyed away from the city
toward my grandparents' provinces
in rural Mongolia
to see where my parents and I came from,
and better understand my own identity.
Growing up, I'd always heard stories
about how Mongolian nomads
were the most hospitable people on earth,
and I wanted to see with my own eyes
whether they really feed
and give shelter to a stranger.
So I set off to the countryside,
driving along dirt roads for hours.
What's incredible about Mongolian nomads
is that the neighbors are often
40 kilometers apart,
and there's no private land ownership
of pasture land in Mongolia.
In a way,
Mongolian nomads
have the complete freedom,
moving about the gorgeous
landscape as they wish.
Eventually, I spotted to humble yurts
and I pulled over.
Yurts, or ger,
are a traditional Mongolian dwelling.
They're made from one hundred
percent natural material,
a wooden frame and floor,
leather rope
and thick blankets
made from felted sheep's wool.
And it takes about only
three to four hours
to assemble or disassemble,
and keeps them warm
through the minus 50 degree
Celsius winters.
Outside the yurt,
the kids were playing
with sheep and goats,
and as I greeted them,
their parents welcomed me inside.
The wife poured me nice warm milk tea,
and the husband offered me food
that they had already
prepared on the table.
After some casual chitchat,
the husband politely asked my purpose,
so I replied bluntly
that I was just traveling
and exploring my grandparents' roots
and that I needed a place to stay
as the sun was setting.
And guess what?
He said I could stay
as long as I needed to,
on one condition.
He asked if I would play the morin khuur,
our traditional Mongolian
horsehead fiddle.
In my head, I couldn't believe
it was coming true.
And the horsehead fiddle
was like a ticket.
When Mongolians find out
that you can play morin khuur,
you're instantly respected.
They say its two strings
express all the events of the world.
I ended up staying
with them for nine days,
and they didn't even ask me to leave.
I think if I tried
to stay there for two months,
they would have let me.
And here's the thing:
before I met them,
I assumed that Mongolian nomads
were hospitable out of kindness
like anybody else.
But then I realized it was more than that.
It was about surviving as a community.
Because nomads live
in extremely remote areas,
they are completely
at the mercy of nature.
Heavy snowfall,
a sudden flood
or a raging storm
can devastate a nomadic family.
Today, it's a stranger who needs help,
but tomorrow, it could be you.
That's why they look out for each other
and welcome anyone in need of help.
This really touched my heart,
because I feel like we humans
are becoming more and more selfish.
Staying with a truly nomadic
family awakened me.
It was nothing like I've ever seen
in developed countries.
The wife of the family
showed me how they produce
organic dairy products from scratch,
like white cheese, yogurt, tsegee,
and even a traditional vodka
made from cow milk.
And every tool they use
is made from natural material by hand.
And inside the yurt,
we burned dried cow dung to stay warm
instead of using fuel.
Everything stood in sharp contrast
to my city life
filled with plastic and steel.
And this was a five-senses
experience to me,
a completely different
form of sophistication.
The more I traveled across remote
and rural destinations in Mongolia,
the more I understood
how ancient nomadic lifestyle
was powered by Mother Nature.
Nomadic life is truly zero waste.
Over the course of six years,
I visited more than 20 families,
and my experience was always the same.
They invited me in, offered me food
and gave me a place to stay
if I needed it.
I was surprised by how little they owned.
At first, I thought it was because
they moved about four times a year.
OK, that's a very simple
logic to understand.
You only carry what you need.
But then I learned
there's a deeper philosophy behind it.
Historically, nomads believed
that we are only
passing through this life,
that people come and leave naked,
so they believe that there's no point
in building anything that destroys nature
or in being greedy
for materialistic things
when your life expectancy
is only less than 100 years.
Instead, they invest in tradition,
heritage, history,
and pass it from generation to generation.
This ancient nomadic philosophy
made me realize that I should think bigger
and further than my own
convenience and comfort.
In the Mongolian countryside,
I felt a true form of freedom,
and every time I came back to the city,
I looked for ways to live more minimally.
I digitalized all of my company's
paper procedures.
What once took 20 packs of A4 paper
now takes just one.
I downsized my apartment,
reduced my carbon footprint
and picked up a habit
to rethink my actions,
like purchasing, choosing transportation,
and many other lifestyle choices
at home and work.
And most importantly,
I stopped working on fast-moving
consumer-goods marketing projects
and now work with organizations
that promote sustainability.
But by far the biggest change
is that I've started to see development
with fresh eyes.
In cities,
living in a traditional yurt as a nomad
and having less
is often interpreted as a sign of poverty,
not just abroad
but at home in Mongolia too.
We think that the end goal
for every developing country
is to become the next Tokyo
or New York City,
with their skyscrapers,
big shopping malls and toll roads.
Communities around the world are
abandoning their traditional lifestyles
in pursuit of material wealth.
But let's not forget,
the developed countries
are the ones most responsible
for climate change.
So we have to ask ourselves,
why do we keep on following
the same blueprint
when we know it causes harm to the world?
We've all experienced
the consequences of our choices
over the past eight months.
So doing right by Mother Nature
and focusing on earth-friendly,
zero-waste habits
is not an option anymore.
And who knows the key ingredients
better than our ancestors,
the ones who survived without the media
or technology
but with wisdom alone?
As a citizen of Mongolia,
I grew up hearing
that developing countries are inferior,
and I really took it to heart.
But today, I want to say loud and clear
that I don't see disadvantages
from developing countries anymore.
On the contrary,
I see countries that have
the biggest opportunity
to do things in the right way,
countries that can define
their own kind of development
and have the most advantage
to build a better and safer environment
for everyone.
What worked for our ancestors
for thousands of years
can work for us now,
and in the future,
when combined with the latest innovations.
After all, we're all guests in this world,
so let's do right
by the earth and each other
just like the ancient
Mongolian nomads did.
Thank you.